- [Narrator] There's a world
renowned topiary garden
in the tiny town of
Bishopville, South Carolina,
and that garden was created by this man;
a man named Pearl.
(lively, bouncy music)
- [Pearl] I'm Pearl Fryar,
and this is my garden.
- [Narrator] Pearl
started the garden in 1981
with the goal of winning Yard of the Month
from the local garden club.
- [Narrator] There was
a stereotype at the time
that African Americans
didn't keep up their yards.
- [Narrator] Pearl now
has over 300 plants,
most of which were
throwaways that came from
the recycling bin at a local nursery.
- [Narrator] So many people
drove by Pearl's house
to see his garden that he
opened it up to the public.
- Hey, that looks like a sheep!
- A big sheep.
- What else do you want
to look at on the map?
(chiming)